g
what is the percentage chance that you
actually could be filming deadpool 3
next year the percentage chance
uh i don't know i couldn't assign a
percentage to that
um i'd say it's like 50 50 maybe i mean
we're
we're really actively developing it and
getting it into pretty good shape so
um what's what the hell month is it's
august oh next year probably pretty good
i don't know i'd say pretty damn good
i'd say 70 percent
yeah you made me nervous when you said
50 i'm like [ __ ] that's not
that's well i know but i i'm a person
who has absolutely a no sense of
direction
i'm i can i can get lost in a closet and
then b
i have no sense of time my wife will be
like wasn't that like in august that
that thing happened or july i'll be like
i don't know of 1880 i can't i have no
sense of time
it's terrible you are a very talented
writer and i'm curious how are you
working
are collaborating if you will on the
script can you give people
like a status update uh
you know i mean it's just it's it's
something that we just
is it is a daily process i mean writing
is kind of like that you gotta you gotta
a lot time to do it and then walk away
and and uh
um i'm working with the moneos on it
it's been great they're
incredibly talented it's so so smart so
understand that world and
know how to zig when when everyone's
expecting a zag so
it's been it's been a lot of fun